[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right
the
this is one i had my eye on we saw it at
the xbox suitcase i believe and let's
just get right into it
unfortunately it also occurs that slowly
kills it whoa so yeah so they have only
one night left to solve the mystery of
his father's death
and to find a way to detour
to what
we call the limbo
we now are in a in uh benedict's father
consciousness
and whenever brother is dead but we can
still explore his ego is
what we call limbo
which is a distorted version of spouse
it's like his memory towards the house
gotcha
i'm seeing this video and platforming
already
because in the real world benedict is
like a detective he uses his senses
to see to observe and so on
but the demon feels emotions so he's
like a detective here he can tell
benedict what he senses that the father
feared something
that's really cool
our father
to recharge
um
so now let's open some pretty jars
whoa creepy door it's very creepy okay
okay
so we got a little puzzle oh so we got
the okay
and representing representation to the
buttons
we gather
so i can move in one direction and
instantly dodge
okay
and we also reward the exploration
because we have two currencies one
rewarded for combat and one for
exploration the one for exploration we
used to buy and upgrade the item and the
other one the ink that we collect from
demons we used to tattoo benedict and
gather new skills okay so
[Music]
[Music]
available
more mpcs to utilize
so we show that for now we show that uh
harry houdini who is our shopkeeper
and the mysterious standard
and hello maybe oh my god okay okay hold
it i love this
yeah visually we wanted to create the
contrast between a cartoony hard side
with a lot of colors
with some
very mature and intimate storytelling to
create a friction there
and this kind of naturally
makes us closer to for example tim
barton's work yes that's the vibe it's
funny
story-wise
to
that you could initiate that at yeah
uh
so there are few
in a weaker form so you will have less
hp you will still do the same amount of
damage so you need to be cautious
but
later on you will be able to power
through the enemies that you once
defeated
those are like shameful memories that we
sometimes that people
uh over analyze again and again and i
know we're in a loud convention but i'm
assuming because do these parts have
voids acting yeah
and we can push the enemy away
we want to have like a very
good balance between storytelling
it also has like a combat ability
oh that's hard
hey we got finishes
they do it a lot right now benny think
you're doing a lot
let's go
let's try to use this plan
okay so we can use that now can that be
used as an offensive or more of a slam
through to get to different areas
at first it's more of a utility tool
but later on
every ability
has also like a second tattoo on the
other hand that can enhance the ability
so later on you will be able to deal
of the um
so now we've got additional
help
i like that little trail behind it oh
yeah the
companion
oh
[Applause]
what would you like to tell people who
may be on the fence about benefit and
things that maybe we didn't get a chance
to talk about that in the game so
we try
to make the game to be as accountable as
possible so
for every uh major part of the game the
exploration the combat and the puzzle we
will
create a
separate slider and player will be able
to customize the experience for their
lighting so yeah if you don't want the
combat but you want the hardest puzzles
you can get you can do it if you're
interested in exploration we can make it
harder for you
so you give it a customization from
puzzle action depending on the style of
the player and the accessibility plan
you'll give it a personal opposite maybe
they want to challenge themselves you
can do that too
oh pretty cool design so it's an
absolute pleasure the last case of
benedict
xbox game yes xbox 35 day one day one
what are the fireworks
team and uh
epic game store for um
you heard it here first i will be
approved cognito last case infinity
[Music]
welcome to the iron lords